tech pioneer Paul Allen is being
remembered today as the innovative
co-founder of Microsoft and as a
generous philanthropist Allen died
yesterday from non-hodgkins lymphoma he
was just sixty-five years old
in a statement Microsoft co-founder Bill
Gates called Allen a true partner and
dear friend he says that personal
computing would not have existed without
him
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn looks at Allen's varied interest
very powerful legacy glad good morning
good morning Paul Allen was much more
than a Titan in the tech world he owned
three professional sports teams and gave
more than a billion dollars to charity
while investing in ocean space an
alternative power research he said those
fortunate enough to have great wealth
should use it for the good of humanity
Paul Allen was a visionary in the world
of high tech as co-founder of Microsoft
Allen became one of the richest men on
earth with a net worth once estimated at
40 billion dollars it was a company that
he and Bill Gates envisioned when they
were both young teenagers Allen told
Leslie Stahl in an interview for 60
minutes in 2011 he was saying well
imagine what it's like to run a fortune
500 company I'm thinking I have no idea
you know my parents were were librarians
Allen's breakthrough idea in 1974 was to
write software for another company small
computer that led to the home computer
revolution and the birth of Microsoft
after a falling-out with gates Allen
left Microsoft at the age of 30 after he
was first diagnosed with cancer Allen
wrote that facing his own mortality
forced him to reassess his life and
follow other dreams I've got such a
diverse set of interest movies aviation
technology an avid sports fan
Allen bought both the Portland Trail
Blazers and his hometown Seattle
Seahawks and watched them win their
first Super Bowl in 2014 in a statement
Seahawks head coach Pete Carroll says
the world is a better place because of
Paul's passion commitment and
selflessness in recent years Allen's
company Vulcan oversaw his numerous
cultural projects in Seattle including a
museum inspired by his passion for music
as well as his philanthropic efforts
around the world in wildlife
conservation oceans health climate
change infectious diseases it was one of
the great joys of working with ball is
that breadth and diversity of how many
things he wanted to have an impact on
and how big he thought about impact
Allen was treated for non-hodgkins
lymphoma in 2009 he announced just two
weeks ago that it had returned Apple CEO
Tim Cook says our industry has lost a
pioneer and our world has lost a force
for good in addition to you know the
things that we've talked about with
personal computing he recently funded a
forty six million dollar building for
homeless people in South Seattle for
worse were good is a very good way to
describe him yeah you really really
loved life and left a lot of us really
missing what he has done really without
a match I know it's just that he was
something else
Thanks five